what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I am on periscope right now
recording this I don't how many people
actually use the periscope app but it's
mine's at comics explained I think it is
on periscope I don't remember but anyway
so after look into the comments section
after the the final crisis video was
uploaded the final final crisis video
was uploaded I saw there were some
people who were confused and and
rightfully so because that story is
really polarizing we'll talk about Dark
Knight's medal here in a second the dark
multiverse and everything but the nature
of Final Crisis is that that story is
not linear most of the stories we cover
the character explanations we do they're
all really linear they're really
straightforward
so it's like this character first
appeared in this year and they were
created by this person who wrote them
for some amount of time and then they
left
and another person took over and then
they left and another person took over
and all these people contributed to the
expansion of that character or team
pretty straightforward and pretty linear
with stories it's much the same way I
mean Jeff John's Green Lantern is
shaping up to be probably the most
expansive we've done but up until when
that finishes civil war will still be
like the biggest part of the entirety of
storytelling that we do took three
months to finish it was almost 120
issues long but it was still a linear
story some mutant called nitro was given
mutant growth hormone that basically
amplified his powers he blew up Stanford
Connecticut and then humanity responded
Congress had worked in the past
registration Tony Stark agreed Ironman
said yep I agree with that because if we
don't then they're basically them turned
their guns on us
Captain America disagreed superheroes
chose sides they fought and then
eventually Captain America gave up
that's the gist of civil war that's the
plot summary in a nutshell when it comes
to Final Crisis it is anything but it is
like seven or eight different things all
going on at the same time but the reason
why we covered that story is because of
what happens to that man and that leads
us into our discussion of the Dark
multiverse so we've talked about the
multiverse before we've run over the
concept of the multiverse and a lot of
people seem to find it really confusing
and really baffling we've really done
like this short version before and again
the short version is basically that DC
created the multiverse in 1961 and they
focused on like five or six different
universes and that was really about it
that's like multiverse 1.0 basically
then they cancelled it in 1985 with
crisis on Infinite Earths
and then it stayed gone for 20 years
until Infinite Crisis when it came back
but it was
little bit different so we can call that
multiverse 2.0 and then final crisis
made the superheroes aware of it that's
really about it
now following final crisis and if you've
Google search the DC Multiverse you'll
find what's called the map of the
multiverse now the map of the multiverse
was created by writer Grant Morrison
after he finished Final Crisis my
thought is that DC did not intend to
reboot in 2011 their idea was to
basically just focus on each of those
stories within the multiverse the
biggest issue with the map of the
multiverse is I do not think it's a good
representation of how the multiverse
works especially now with the dark
multiverse but the long and short of it
is that if you look at this map you
basically see a whole bunch of earths
with numbers on them those are
essentially representations of entire
universes just because it's easier to
represent a universe with an earth
because I don't know how you would draw
a universe but each one of these earths
is basically a universe unto itself it
has its own Green Lantern core it has
its own Wonderwoman its own pantheon of
Greek gods has its own thing its own kit
and kaboodle going on there the whole
idea is that more sin and company wanted
to focus on each one of those different
universes and the story behind it and
what's going on with it
the problem is in 2011 DC popped up and
said okay we're rebooting so we want you
to pretend with Action Comics number one
as Superman number one that we've never
written a Superman story before the same
thing goes for all the characters who
got new number ones we want you to act
like we've never published them before
this is the very first time you've ever
seen him and what it did is it basically
threw Multiversity out the window
in any event the whole reason why the
Dark multiverse matters and the whole
reason why we covered Final Crisis is
because to me the best way to think of
the multiverse in terms of a physical
representation is a linear number chart
which is to say you start with zero and
then you go one two three four five all
the way up to 52 what we're learning
with Dark Knight's meddle with the Dark
multiverse is there's this whole other
side that we didn't know about before
and so instead of it going with zero one
two three four all the way up to 52 it's
zero in the middle and then negative one
negative two negative three all the way
to negative 52 now the reason why this
is important and the reason why we
covered Final Crisis is because in that
story Batman was hit with the Omega
sanction Omega beams of dark side and
was time-displaced when
he was timed this place what it did is
it Cynthia qwave all throughout the
positive multiverse and all throughout
the negative multiverse because the main
BC universe is earth zero it's right
smack dab in the middle of it all and so
because of that what it basically did is
it woke up this being named barbados and
alerted him to the fact that batman
would be the means by which they could
access the positive multiverse they
would have to travel through the dark
multiverse past and through earth prime
earth zero and into the positive
multiverse to do whatever wasn't they
were gonna do presumably conquer it
that's kind of what I'm assuming but the
whole idea here is that when Batman was
time displaced what barbados began doing
was basically going through all these
different dark multiverse universes and
rounding up these evil versions of
Batman Dawnbreaker Batman where he
became the Green Lantern and killed the
DC Universe the Red Death Batman were he
merged with the flash the man who laughs
was we don't know his story yet we found
all these different versions which were
united under barbados for the purpose of
setting in motion a series of schemes
which we still haven't seen fleshed out
that will ultimately allow them to
access the positive multiverse now one
of the things that the dark multiverse
is introducing and it was really focused
more and like the Red Death one-shot
than anything else is the idea of rules
and these are things that just didn't
really exist before right like there
were never really any rules when it came
to the multiverse it was just whatever
happens will happen like maybe there's a
multiverse where Kyle Jordan never
stopped being parallax and conquered all
of reality we have no idea but the idea
with the dark multiverse is that there
are effectively rules all the different
universes in the dark multiverse are
basically breaking down they're
essentially coming apart of the scenes
we don't exactly know why but DC simply
simply seems to be hitting at the idea
that there always has to be a Batman
there always has to be a flash there
always has to be a Superman but the
arrival to that character has to be done
organically it cannot be forced the
reason I say that is one of the
universes that exists in the positive
multiverse is a universe where Batman
became the Green Lantern but because the
Green Lantern ring chose him and then he
became a good guy he became a hero he
didn't become a villain in the dark
multiverse and Dawnbreaker
yeah the Green Lantern ring chose him
and then he killed the DC Universe and
so because of that they're breaking the
rules they're breaking the idea that
heroes are supposed to be good guys
villains are supposed to be bad guys
Batman became a villain and that's the
kicker of it all the problem with that
the reason why it raises a weird a
suspicion is because of the crime
syndicate of America the comics story
and actually had a really good a really
good idea really good theory where he
basically argued that in truth the crime
syndicate being the evil version of the
Justice League from earth 3 in the
positive universe weren't actually bad
guys they were but they actually made
the world a better place they kept it
safe they got rid of all the criminals
and different things like that so
technically speaking they weren't tried
and true villains but Batman and
Dawnbreaker Batman and Red Death
they're basically bad guys but
regardless of what the reason is behind
why those universes are coming to an end
they're all basically being destroyed
and so as it stands right now with
regards to Dark Knight's medal with
regards to what it is that's going on
the overall gist is that Barbados this
Grand Poobah bat guy whatever it is that
he happens to be presumably the
amalgamation of all evil in the in the
multiverse and the dark multiverse is
what I'm assuming he is that he has
basically rounded up these evil versions
of Batman that we're seeing in these one
shots Dawnbreaker the drowning Red Death
the man who lasts all those different
things and they're effectively going to
and they already have entered the
positive multiverse and they're
currently residing on earth Prime now I
imagine the rest of the story will
basically be an effort to stop them from
spreading throughout the rest of the
multiverse we don't really know we don't
know if they'll corrupt it or whatever
the case may be but that's where things
stand at the moment that's where things
are residing the superheroes are
learning about the Dark multiverse
they're discovering that it exists and
they're discovering by way of these evil
versions of Batman so that's kind of
where things stand at the moment again
we'll see this flesh out more as the
story progresses but that's basically
what the Dark multiverse seems to be the
Dark multiverse explained it's basically
this neo multiverse where everything
that can go wrong has gone wrong anyway
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
hopefully it clears up any confusion
that you guys had if you do have any
questions post them down in the comment
section I'll answer them as best I can
if I don't get to them and somebody
knows the answer
post a reply as well that way somebody
gets a response to the question they're
asking and and yeah so if you guys are
new here to come and explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob port if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
I make the peace on whatever it is that
I actually in my videos
you